[Musica]
io sono sarà ho 43 anni e sono
ipocondriaca claustrofobica e ansiosa e
questa è la mia casa
[Musica]
che cosa ha spinto che cosa mi ha spinto
a vincere le mie fobie le mie paure che
cosa ha spinto ma è mio marito ad
imbarcarsi in questa avventura e
lasciare ogni nostra certezza
quando mi hanno chiesto gli
organizzatori di concludere la domanda
se tutto dipendesse da così d'istinto mi
è venuto di dire dai tuoi sogni e perché
era quello che stavo vivendo in quel
momento
subito mi sono accorta di essere messa
in un guaio pazzesco perché un tema
talmente ampio talmente complesso
talmente personale però ormai l'avevo
combinata quindi dovevo cercare di
rimediare
e allora sono andata dai miei figli dal
più piccolino gli ho detto senti ma che
cos'è per te è un sogno e lui mi ha
risposto mamma i sogni sono una cosa
bellissima che accade mentre dormi e
allora mi sono chiesto iniziato a
riflettere ma perché questa cosa
bellissima deve accadere solo quando noi
stiamo dormendo perché non può esserci
anche quando siamo svegli di fatto un
sogno non esiste un sogno sono delle
immagini che il nostro cervello mette
insieme regalandoci delle emozioni
pazzesco la felicità incredibile che
dura pochissimo difatti per me la
felicità è una cosa che dura pochi
minuti a volte una manciata di secondi è
una cosa che si parte dalla pancia
arriva il cuore ti fa tremare le gambe e
poi sparisce svanisce del resto come i
sogni quando ci svegliamo la mattina
e la felicità dura poco la felicità dura
poco come i sogni e allora forse bisogna
imparare a guardare da un altro punto di
vista
realizzare un sogno sembra quasi una
frase fatta
se una frase che fa paura a volte una
frase forse per pochi e poi realizzare
implica che ci possa essere un
fallimento
e allora mi piace pensarla come i saggi
i saggi dicono seguire i propri sogni
perché perseguire i propri sogni
nel percorso per seguire i propri sogni
c'è un viaggio e questo viaggio si
chiama vita quindi mi piace pensarla il
mio pensiero è che un sogno non è
raggiungere un obiettivo ma
avere un obiettivo da raggiungere
noi avevamo un sogno io mio marito
avevamo un sogno avevamo un progetto che
poi è diventata la nostra vita e quindi
dopo essere stati abili sognatori
abbiamo dovuto diventare degli abili
costruttori di sogni e ci sono degli
elementi secondo me fondamentali che non
bisogna non bisogna tralasciare bisogna
avere innanzitutto un progetto bisogna
avere delle idee chiare e soprattutto
bisogna essere liberi dalle aspettative
e poi bisogna fare i conti con delle
paroloni molto grossi una fra questa e
cambiamento il cambiamento mi viene in
mente per esempio è un domino il domino
per regalare il suo spettacolo ha
bisogno di un primo tocco e per mettere
in azione il cambiamento bisogna fare un
primo passo e c'è proprio una frase che
mi piace ea cui faccio spesso
riferimento che dice che il primo passo
del cambiamento non è andare dove vuoi
ma è allontanarti da dove sei
nella vita di tutti i giorni noi siamo
tutti curiosi
siamo curiosi dietro i social di spiare
la vita degli altri siamo curiosi di
vivere la vita degli altri però non
siamo curiosi di provare a vedere come
andrebbe la nostra vita sessuale
alzassimo lo sguardo dal monitor
io mio marito siamo stati spioni abbiamo
spiato la vita di quelli che viaggiavano
di quelli che navigavano di quelli che
avevano scelto il mare e la barca come
casa e poi è successa una cosa che la
curiosità è diventata invidia e
l'invidia è diventata frustrazione e
allora ci siamo detti un certo punto ma
perché loro sì e noi no
che cosa hanno loro in più di noi che
non possiamo fare anche noi e allora
successa un'altra cosa che curiosità e
ispirazione hanno preso lo spazio della
frustrazione
allora abbiamo smesso di essere
spettatori
abbiamo pensato che comunque vada non
abbiamo una vita per guardare e una vita
per fare in fondo non abbiamo neanche
le vite dei gatti
però possiamo scegliere di vivere come
se le avessimo
noi avevamo energia avevamo le idee
chiare avevamo il coraggio avevamo le
competenze anche se in mare le
competenze non sono mai abbastanza
l'unica cosa che non avevamo erano i
soldi un certo punto non potevamo
aspettare i soldi della pensione non
potevamo aspettare quell'eredità magari
dello zio d'america oppure come le carte
del monopoly la vita era adesso a 40
anni dovevamo giocarci tutto subito
adesso ma come fare
e così è successo che abbiamo iniziato a
pensare che la vita va vissuta e non
potevamo aspettare di raggiungere il
nostro sogno per viverla e quindi
abbiamo iniziato a far prendere una
piega diversa la nostra vita abbiamo
iniziato a metterci in questo cammino
abbiamo cercato di capire che cosa
serviva la prima cosa erano i soldi per
comprare una barca
e quindi abbiamo improntato la nostra
vita su questo abbiamo cercato di capire
che forse non dovevamo trovare i soldi
dobbiamo smettere di trovare le scuse e
trasformarle in soluzioni
abbiamo così cambiato la nostra vita
abbiamo eliminato il superfluo
abbiamo deciso che niente cene fuori
niente statista la macchina al telefono
anche se erano vecchi chissenefrega
andavano bene comunque ore ora extra di
lavoro i bambini avevano i vestiti usati
chissenefrega andava bene così e ancora
non ce la facevamo e allora abbiamo
detto va bene abbiamo una casa
mettiamola in affitto abbiamo messo la
nostra casa in affitto siamo andati a
vivere per tre anni con mio padre ci
siamo trasferiti da milano a un paesino
di tremila anime tutto questo non
dimentichiamoci con tre bambini a
seguito quindi insomma potete capire la
complessità della cosa e ancora non ce
la facevamo e allora siamo arrivati alla
drastica decisione di dover vendere la
nostra casa di cui mettere ancora della
banca ma questo è un altro discorso
e vendere la nostra casa è stato
era stato sarà stato è stato vendere la
nostra casa è stata la scelta più
dolorosa di tutta la mia vita però
purtroppo quando siamo di fronte a delle
scelte quando vogliamo raggiungere un
obiettivo un sogno dobbiamo scegliere e
volte le scelte dolorose sono
inevitabili come è stato così per noi
per me e per noi tutta la famiglia
succede poi che andiamo in grecia
in un campo così quasi semiabbandonata
troviamo la barca che faceva per noi
abbiamo ci siamo informati insomma
riuscivamo ad averla da un prezzo
favorevole di 60 mila euro che però
avremmo dovuto trovare in una settimana
tutti gli sforzi fatti negli anni
precedenti non bastava non arrivavano a
tanto allora abbiamo messo da parte
l'orgoglio abbiamo preso in mano il
telefono abbiamo iniziato a chiamare
parenti amici che in una settimana
shibumi era nostra
i soldi poi li abbiamo restituiti appena
abbiamo venduto alla casa è stato facile
tutto questo no è stato possibile tutto
questo si sono stati anni difficilissimi
soprattutto gli anni quando abbiamo
passato mesi e mesi in cantiere tra
l'altro i lavori li abbiamo fatti noi
perché ovviamente non avevamo le
possibilità economica di gravare su
altri di contare su altri e quindi mesi
e mesi in cantiere con i bambini sono
stati veramente dei momenti molto
difficili e io mio marito spesso ci
guardavamo in faccia ci dicevamo ma ce
la faremo ce la faremo mai a raggiungere
il nostro sogno è la frase poi era
sempre la stessa
noi ce la stiamo già facendo
egli poi ci sono gli imprevisti
in tutti questi anni ho avuto tre aborti
ho avuto anni di attacchi di panico
crisi economica e crisi lavorative però
del resto questi sono gli imprevisti gli
imprevisti fanno parte della vita in
quanto tale un imprevisto non è
prevedibile nel nostro progetto di vita
nel nostro programma
eppure li abbiamo superati perché
abbiamo la fortuna abbiamo la fortuna
nella vita di avere un piano b perché il
piano b non è un ripiego ma un piano b è
un'opportunità
mi è capitato per esempio di essere in
coda state andando in vacanza e siete in
coda in autostrada fermi bloccati
avete due possibilità
stare fermi e aspettare che la coda si
sciolga da sola si risolva da sola
oppure potete scegliere di prendere una
strada alternativa e magari vi trovate
in una strada di campagna
il movimento diventa più più morbido
magari vi fermate a fare una passeggiata
magari vi fermate vedere il panorama
magari vi fermate perché avete bucato
oppure incontrate delle persone una
trattoria e magari in quel posto vicino
a voi c'è una borgo che non potete
perdere
e allora succede che magari la vostra
meta finale non ve ne frega più niente
di raggiungerla perché il vostro piano b
non è stato un ripiego è stata
un'opportunità di vedere scoprire e di
vivere
questo è quello che è successo un po a
noi noi avevamo a grandi linee delle
rotte definite che prevedevano grecia
italia abbiamo fatto cantiere poi
baleari gibilterra canaria capo verde e
poi traversata atlantica
successo che siamo partiti in ritardo
ovviamente la pandemia ci ha rallentato
nei lavori riusciamo a partire solo in
inverno e quindi abbiamo fatto una
navigazione invernale il mediterraneo
che non è proprio semplicissima e quindi
abbiamo ritardato parecchio
riusciamo arrivare alle baleari a
formentera nello specifico ea primi di
gennaio
ok facciamo un paio di giorni di sosta
facciamo cambusa sistemi a due cose
ripartiamo
la mattina del 10 gennaio prendo in mano
la radio shibumi shibumi sta per
lasciare il porto
la capitaneria risponde shibumi non può
l'isola è chiusa per la pandemia
insomma in un secondo tutto s'è
sgretolata sotto i nostri piedi siamo
rimasti bloccati per otto mesi ci siamo
giocati la casa ci siamo giocati il anno
di aspettativa perché non avremmo potuto
averne un altro l'organizzazione con la
scuola l'organizzazione quel lavoro
tutto quello che avevamo fatto negli
altri negli anni precedenti è andato in
fumo l'abbiamo perso proprio in
quell'istante in cui ci hanno detto che
tutto era bloccato perché gli alisei non
ci aspettavano non avremmo potuto
rimandare perché sarebbe saltato tutto
quanto è tra l'altro non è che ci sia
andata malissimo perché potevamo
giocarci in un altro post in realtà se
rimasti fermi in un paradiso una perla
del mediterraneo
è però abbiamo iniziato a guardare
quello che avevamo e non quello che
abbiamo perso abbiamo deciso che per
rifare rifarci una vita a rimetterci in
piedi ricostruirci rimetterci in gioco
non potevamo continuare a piangere con
quello che abbiamo perso ma dovevamo
guardare quello che avevamo e dalla
nostra avevamo le competenza scientifica
avevamo la creatività avevamo tre
bambini e avevamo un sacco i contenuti
e allora ci è venuta questa idea siamo
diventati un associazione
siamo diventati un associazione che si
chiama shibumi floating lab la barca è
una mezzo pulito ed è un laboratorio
perfetto per poter ospitare progetti di
ogni tipo sulla sostenibilità
soprattutto noi siamo autonomi e
sostenibili la nostra energia con cui
viviamo tutti i giorni arriva solo dal
vento e dal sole vediamo e la via e ci
laviamo con l'acqua di sali nata del
mare e quindi abbiamo trovato
interessante raccontare tutto questo e
divulgare tutto questo così è nata a
shibumi per la scuola entriamo nelle
scuole shibumi per le aziende
entriamo nelle aziende e siccome per
l'ambiente tutto questo e divulgazione
testimonianza progetti che alla fine
hanno arricchito la nostra aprire la
nostra nuova vita non avremmo mai detto
nella nostra vita che ci saranno in
barca menati in questa cosa in questa
attività eppure questo è successo
abbiamo fatto un progetto molto molto
bello interessante con l'istituto
nazionale di fisica nucleare di cui
abbiamo il patrocinio che l'ente per il
quale lavora mio marito ed è nata la
serie della fisica tra le onde
praticamente i nostri figli da bambini
per bambini hanno fatto una serie
improntata sulla sostenibilità
energetica una serie di dieci puntate
che andata in onda anche sulla rai dove
con termini da bambini spiegano i
bambini quello che noi stavamo vivendo
la nostra quotidianità e poi con questa
sempre con quest'ente abbiamo fatto una
serie molto interessante sui raggi
cosmici perché a bordo ospitiamo un
rivelatore di raggi cosmici e quindi
sulle isole nelle grotte sui vulcani
insomma ovunque noi stiamo portiamo
avanti questi progetti e facciamo
esperimenti e molto divertente perché
coinvolge i bambini e comunque è
interessante quando entriamo nelle
scuole anche facciamo interviste a
biologi marini quando portiamo le nostre
esperienze
i bambini sono curiosi bambini sono
abiti delle di di sapere e soprattutto
quando parliamo dello stato del mare e
di come viviamo noi in modo sostenibile
perché il domani
e dei nostri figli dei bambini e quindi
bisogna partire dal basso e qui insomma
ci siamo dati un altra opportunità la
nostra vita adesso ha avuto un'altra
piega che mai avremmo pensato di avere
nella nostra vita
successivamente a formentera
abbiamo parcato le colonne d'ercole
siamo entrati in oceano abbiamo fatto
cinque giorni di navigazione fino alle
canarie e attualmente da ottobre viviamo
alle canarie mio marito fa il pendolare
lanzarote milano i miei figli sono
iscritti a scuola li io porto avanti
progetti dell'associazione porta avanti
i miei progetti come creativa digitale e
segue il nostro account social che anche
quello un bel lavoro impegnativo
in quanto io vedrò la serenità negli
occhi della mia famiglia dei miei figli
saprò che quella la strada giusta
infine vi lascio con questo pensiero che
io non so alla fine sarà aggiunto il
ministro io me non ho ancora ben capito
l'unica cosa che ho capito è che ho
imparato in questi ultimi 15 anni e che
i sogni non fa venir al cielo i sogni
bisogna andare a prendersi grazie
[Musica]